the protest here in Great Neck are
nothing in fact I would suggest that the
protest over her willingness to speak to
us and for us to be willing to listen to
her here are a good
sign we Jews especially love to speak
anyone who's opened up a
talut and engaged with the with our wise
ones
knows that very few topics are off the
table as long as you speak respectfully
and
courteously with that I will invite
Pamela Geller to address us
I can
speak
Hali first I I I must take a moment to
thank Rabbi
ginski who in in the
[Applause]
face in the face of enormous pressure
you must see you must see what this
issue how critical this issue is how
toxic this issue is for one little Jew
to speak to a men's club on a Sunday
morning such a
firestorm it's indicative
of how bad things
are it's indicative of the war on free
speech and for me it's an honor to be
here at kabad because those of us who
were involved in the fight and I want to
thank many of my esteemed colleagues
that are here Dr Andrew bstone Charles
Jacobs I want to thank ashra rala voice
of the cops many of my esteemed
colleagues are here
we know that kabad is a touchstone in
this war kabad is always a Target by
jihadists always I don't know if it's
the beauty of kabad the goodness of
kabad but that terrorist attack in
Mumbai that gruesome terrorist attack
where 166 people were
killed and all of the Muslims were
released they were all released just
like in Algeria the hostage crisis last
month all all 600 were released the
number one target the number one target
was the kabad
house and I will not because we're in
the kabad I will not discuss what was
done to the rabbi and his wife but it is
beyond your imagination what went on in
the kabad house and if you read don't
take my word for it read the texts of
the cell phone conversations that were
having with headquarters in Pakistan and
of course as you know the ICI the
Pakistani spy agency was
involved now to
[Music]
listen to Greg
Buckley to listen to the pain of a
father is the human
cost is the human cost of this
fantasist delusion that we are pursuing
all over the
world not just in Afghanistan but in
America you tell me why his son didn't
have a gun after Fort
Hood because Fort Hood was workplace
violence that's
why here you had a Jihadi major ad Al
Hassan who came out on Grand
rounds his PowerPoint presentation is so
powerful that if I had an AV I would use
it to show you and explain what the jih
hadic
doctrine he was wearing the Garb of the
Shahid the suicide uh the Martyr he was
giving out qurans the morning of his
Jihad he was screaming Al abbar Allah is
greater greater than what greater than
your
God and it's workplace violence
so it's not just that they don't care
it's that they are pursuing a pro
jihadist foreign policy now people will
say oh you're really out there with that
line Geller you're really out there I
don't Pro jihadist that's too far really
so you tell me why in June July and
August of 2009 when the only real
Freedom Revolution was taking place in
Iran how did you know that you didn't
have to be a rocket scientist it was led
by women
and because they have been living under
the boot since
1979 was it perfect it wasn't perfect
but it was real and they are the head of
the snake and they are funding they are
hisbah and they're funding Hamas and
they're agitating in Bahrain and they
were killing our soldiers in Iraq and
they are they were funding the Taliban
years
ago but that was the only Freedom
Revolution Obama would not support and
they were holding signs we're sorry for
Obama you're either with us or against
us remember he ignored it but Mubarak
our Ally for 30
years the first Muslim country to make a
peace with Israel okay he he throws away
with both
hands throws away with both hands and
you can say well you know we it started
out well it never started out well if
you go to my site or Robert Spencer's
site we were saying in January of 2011
the Muslim Brotherhood is going to uh
seize this moment we we have been
documenting it for years and it wasn't
accidental because Obama invited the
Muslim Brotherhood to his speech in
Cairo in 2009 when they had been
outlawed Mubarak was
livid they had been outlawed and he
invites it and subsequent to that
speech his mid-level cabinet officials
are meeting with the Muslim Brotherhood
that was no accident just so that you
know like oh we didn't know we it was
Freedom it was an Islamic revolution an
Islamic supremacist Revolution and it's
the same thing like what were we doing
in
Libya we don't get our oil from Libya
French let the French fight what were we
doing in Libya oh he was a bad guy Ki
was a bad guy yeah yeah he was a bad guy
there's worse a jihadist revolution in
Libya is worse and you see these things
are not static they're fluid what
happens Mali gets taken over becomes a
terror state they're falling like
dominoes across the world catastrophic
consequences and the Jews the most
reviled of all in Islam I mean I have
these flyers I didn't put them out
because I'm in aabad and I have respect
even though I do not have respect for
the Islamic texts and teachings that
call for the annihilation of the Jews I
don't have respect for that don't ask me
to respect it I won't because what we
saw here at the Great
[Applause]
what we saw at the Great Neck synagogue
was the sanction of the
victim I want you to think about what I
just said evil is made possible irran
said by the sanction you give it
withdraw your
sanction I am accused of being a hater
and being a bigot and so on and so forth
because that is the war that we are in
we are in the war in the information
battle
space the war of ideas and all the
bullets and the bombs and the Bloodshed
comes as a result of what happens in
this war and part of the war is to
destroy and I mean destroy anyone that
speaks the truth what is truth truth is
the recognition of
reality anyone that speaks the truth it
is the
mission of
yehudim to speak the
emis it is our duty to speak the truth
no matter the
cost and anyone that speaks to this
issue is demonized marginalized smeared
and rendered
radioactive you you know and what is
that that's the Sharia you know under
the Sharia there are blasphemy laws you
cannot criticize Islam you cannot offend
Islam
in Muslim countries if you blaspheme
you're put to death that's a penalty for
blasphemy now you could say oh well you
know uh if you slander slander even if
it's true it's considered slander under
Islam so in the west you don't get
assassinated but they assassinate your
character they destroy your good name
they destroy your credibility you can't
make a living they destroy people who
wants to speak to this issue who will
take this on
we must all stand
up I I think the reason why the media
became so in love with this story is
because when it evolved from Habib ammed
the executive director of The Long
Island um uh the uh Mosque of Long
Island uh Islamic Center I'm sorry
Islamic Center of Long Island and he
used as we know his Pol political office
Nassau County Human Rights commissioner
to Strongarm the Sho and then of course
liberal Jews you know Rabbi uh Davidson
picked up on it that's when the media
frenzy really began Jew against Jew and
they loved
it and you know because it is a war in
the information battle space and because
the media is the enemy I call them the N
media they are the largest weapon that
our adversaries have in their Arsenal
[Applause]
[Music]
these ads that I do okay uh first of all
every single ad was a response to a Lial
a facius smear every single one in the
case of the Israel a that David was
talking about I there was one and I
didn't respond it wasn't until the
second and the third ones that I said
okay this this is this is off the charts
now again this is the that caused such a
brewhaha in any war between the
Civilized man and the Savage support the
Civilized man support Israel defeat
Jihad now Savage is an uncivilized
person and I submit to you that the war
in
Israel is a war on innocent civilians
you show me where it hasn't been the
Rockets being fired from from Gaza into
schools into towns into homes the
slaughter of the Fogo family in the
middle of the night a three 3month old
baby
beheaded the blowing up of the bus in
Bulgaria Jewish women and children on
holiday you show me where the war
against the Jews the Jihad against the
Jews has not been
Savage now Rabbi Davidson says that my
ad I called all Muslims animals I'm
asking you a question is he bearing
false witness or not
[Applause]
I don't spread hate I expose hate and we
must talk about it I we must talk about
it thank you um I I don't have time to
go into all the ad campaigns but there
is a war going on it's
covert it is to disarm the American
people because if the look yes to disarm
the American
people I don't worry about the
fanaticism of the enemy I worry about
the confusion on our
[Music]
[Applause]
side the Muslim Brotherhood group the
Hamas group Care Council of American
Islamic relation who the media calls the
Muslim um Civil Rights group okay I'm
the hate group I'm not one I'm not two
I'm five according to the southern poty
Law
Center and the ADL who by the way
yesterday criticized is Israel is
outraged at Israel because Israel uh
told one of the Eurovision contestants
not to wear gallano now look gallano you
know he's bad news you never see Israel
address any anti-Semitism but when a guy
is up there you know screaming into the
cameras I love Hitler you you know is
that's what happened but foxmen and ADL
they're outraged foxmen and ADL they're
outraged at Joan
Rivers and Seth
mcfallen okay what are the they doing
first of all they shouldn't be the
Anti-Defamation League they should be
the defamation
League every Jew that gives money today
really should evaluate where your money
is going and what are the results you
should you're all businessmen you should
be results oriented in your philanthropy
as well here we have the Council of
American Islamic relations a Hamas group
so named not by Pamela Geller by the US
government and the large
terrorist funding trial in our nation's
history the Holy Land Foundation trial
running ads rebranding
Jihad my Jihad is to stay fit despite my
business
schedule this is a serious
campaign so I said okay I I instituted a
campaign where I use five high-profile
Muslims their actual quotes and I had to
substantiate them you know the the
Washington said oh we don't believe we
don't believe this we want to see
substantiation um you have the the Prime
Minister of Turkey who said the mosques
are our uh fortresses the minettes are
our bayonets and the Muslims are our
soldiers okay and we have of course uh
this is from Hamas MTV killing Jews is
worship that draws Us close to Allah
what's interesting about this campaign I
have six ads and only this one only this
one got publicity and this ad campaign
where I'm showing actual quotes there's
Osama he said the first thing that we
are calling you is to Islam this is this
is what they said you know here's shake
kadai the leader of the Muslim brother
across the world the punishment of
homosexuality is a death penalty now why
did I do that one because San Francisco
the mecca of the homosexual Community
the city council actually had a press
conference and cond me and the ads and
then issued a resolution the first of
its kind so I said okay but will you
condemn what they're saying in the ads
no and who found that out but a blogger
media never asked them the media never
asked them and even crazier gets crazy
I'm telling you this is we're living in
an orwellian
age the leader of the Human Rights
Council in San
Francisco
transgender said this is true said well
you know it's easier to get a
transgender operation in Iran because I
one of my one of my uh homosexual
homosexual has you know um akad saying
we have no homosexuals in
Iran and the reason why they have no
homosexuals in Iran is because they make
them get transgender
operations this is the disconnect but
you see how pervasive you see how
pervasive it is you see how I'm disra
cribed immediately always described as
anti-muslim I'm not anti-muslim I'm
anti- Jihad and I'm anti- Sharia and
they're implying that all Muslims
support these acts of jihad they're
implying that all Muslims support Sharia
they're implying that by calling me that
they say well you know not every Muslim
you know is a jihadist I said of course
not but I don't have to pat on the back
every Muslim that doesn't want to kill
me
[Applause]
that's my bar that's my bar now you see
in
Afghanistan these green on Blue attacks
have escalated with the sanction of the
Taliban you see that Obama has pressed
carai to make uh to to make a political
deal with with the Taliban while they
are poisoning the children in the
schools the girls schools while they're
slaughtering slaughtering our soldiers I
mean talk about sitting ducks I don't
know how you when when your son was over
there how you could even cope with what
was going on and the policy that was
going on and knowing that your son was
just in the middle of it you know and
and and by the way by the way the
military the military sends out a memo
that says we have to watch domestic hate
groups and Atlas shrugs is in there
yeah you're
laughing in this long list Christian
groups you got to see this list not one
Jihadi group not one you've got to wake
up you've got to wake up you have to
listen to me if you don't burn the Quran
read the Quran it's all in there the
problem is there is a jih hadic doctrine
that calls for slay the
unbelievers wherever you may find them
and it's not just that it's a m is it is
Myriad texts and quotes it is a
commandment it is not like the Bible it
is not like in Judaism where you know we
if there's two Jews in the room there
are three opinions question question
question you are not allowed to question
in under Islam if you know you attempt
to reform if you attempt to reform or
reinterpret the word of Allah you know
it was the word of Allah it's not like
the Bible that was written by men yes
it's God's word but written by men no
this is the word of Allah is given to
Muhammad if you attempt to reinterpret
it you you are guilty of hypocrisy
hypocrisy is punishable by death
apostasy is punishable by death what
worries me is that the media in this
country and the culture is self-
enforcing the Sharia you cannot
criticize Islam you cannot offend Islam
this is what they're doing so we can't
even have this discussion look what it
took to get this think for a second of
the brewhaha The Firestorm the pressure
that the rabbi came under in Great Neck
look that Rabbi was very strong I'm
going to tell you I I've been cancelled
in the best
[Applause]
places it is overwhelming this is not a
partisan issue it has become a partisan
issue but it is not it is a life and
death issue it is a civilizational issue
we have to have a civilizational spine
the
Jews it is unforgivable what the
American diaspora is doing our brothers
in Europe Europe are being wiped out
Norway will be Juden Ry in a couple of
weeks the last 819 Jews are out of there
Malmo Denmark France a 100,000 are
fleeing
France what is being accomplished today
is exactly what Hitler attempted to
accomplish and it is Islamic
anti-Semitism it is in the Quran we have
to talk about it we need our Interfaith
Partners you know our Interfaith
partners that are always silencing our
rabbis
to speak to call for sponging the Quran
of the violent texts that Inspire Jihad
that's what we have to
do what can I do I don't know why there
is this approach that people think the
problem is so big I can't solve it you
know I can't get my arms around it you
know it's like a doctor when there's an
epidemic and he's like I can't cure
everybody of course not you can't cure
everybody but you have a sphere of
influence you you you treat who you can
treat every single one of you have lives
in this room there may very well be a
million people meaning you have friends
now I know there are people that are not
going to want to talk about it we all
know those dogmatic mentally ill okay
people yeah they can't they they they
can't you say a is a they're like no not
necessarily no no no a is a no I you're
wrong about that and that's because
you're a racist islamophobic anti Muslim
that's why a is not you have a sphere of
uence you need to speak you need to
speak at every turn you know during the
course of your day you hear things that
you let go do not let them go do not let
them go first learn everything there are
there are Scholars here in the audience
Robert Spencer Dove hkin who's been just
an amazing a giant you know a
giant because anybody anybody that
stands up to this issue is a giant it's
wither withing it's withering believe me
you would not want to be me you know
trust me on this it's unbelievable which
that but I know that I'm right and I
know that we are righteous and I know
that we're doing the right thing and I
applaud you for coming and I I I I beg
that you support the rabbi because this
man is singular I mean he's singular he
he's it's a divine
it's a Divine hand that I'm here and I
ask that you talk speak in capital
letters with an exclamation point speak
because together united we will win we
are right and we are righteous and
remember withdraw your
sanction thank you
[Applause]
I I don't know who they ask all I do is
work oh yeah okay very briefly anybody
that wants to do a Q&A because you know
we really he snuck Us in here at the
last minute that Wy Rabbi be seated
everyone oh there is I'm doing it right
now there's a free speech demo free
speech demo just very briefly very
briefly Free Speech demo at 1:00 240 Old
Country Road in front of the Nassau
County Human Rights Commission where
Habib ahmed's office is because abib
ammed used his political office to
strong on Mich to Crush free speech I
know you're busy I know that you you you
you have other things to do but I but I
implore you anyone that could be there
you know you make out your Wills you
make out your estate you think boy you
know I've taken care of my children you
have not taken care of your children you
are leaving your children to a world
that is Unthinkable because just as we
love our grandparents for for saving us
from from the greatest scorge the
greatest evil our children our
grandchildren are going to hate us
they're going to hate us they will
despise us for leaving them held hostage
to nuclear Islamic regimes believe me on
this you don't need to you don't need to
to be a soothsayer to see what's coming
so 2:40 Old Country Road 1:00 just on
your way to lunch I know you're planning
that I know you are okay on your way to
lunch stop by just give Hollow will be
there with flags no controversial signs
unless unless you know hate speech you
know the truth is a new hate speech and
so truth is controversial well you got
to stand up you got to stand
up thank you